although busting with the boys claimed
that theovan's remarks were unprovoked
Theo says that his reasoning for the
beef stems from being on the receiving
end of a prank where will Compton
convinced him that fella barcel Sports
employee and Theo's good friend Caleb
Presley had suddenly passed away
people were dying dude and then you say
you guys said you did you know I got
that text on that airplane and that's
when Will Compton said that you died
yeah so we got up I got out Will Compton
comes and visits me for in the hospital
and I told him what happened my family's
telling what happened because it was
funny afterwards they think it scared
them in the moment he's like we'll send
a video Let's Tell Theo you died tell
Theo you did it and he died so he texted
you and he was like dude did you hear
what happened to Caleb and you hit him
back right away you're like what
happened and he was like he passed away
and then he immediately took a photo of
me
doing like this in my little gown but
then you're on a plane so the photo
didn't come in the photo didn't come
yeah like yeah was I was at a little
much and far absolutely but anything for
a nice little laugh yeah